سانجاي يخرج بكتاب جديد أخبرتك أنه قادم يسمى دروس الحرب العالمية ج من جائحة covet 19 وكيف تستعد للكتاب التالي ، ما هو الإلهام الذي تعرفه أليس من المضحك أن تقوم بالتلفزيون أعتقد أن كمية المعلومات والمعرفة التي أحاول استيعابها حتى لأفعلها معك بضع دقائق كل ليلة ربما تكون 20 ضعفًا لواحد صحيح ، لقد أخذت 20 ضعفًا من المعلومات التي يمكنني أن أوضحها لك ، أعني كل هذه الأوراق لك أعلم أنني كنت أقوم بتدوين هذه الملاحظات وفعل كل هذه الأشياء وشعرت أن هناك الكثير من الدروس التي تعلمتها ، وتحدثت إلى العلماء في جميع أنحاء العالم والشيء الذي استمر في الظهور مرارًا وتكرارًا هو أنه من الممكن بشكل أساسي أن تجعل نفسك دليلًا على الجائحة من مسببات الأمراض الناشئة التي سوف تستمر في حدوث هذه الفيروسات الناشئة ، لكن فكرة تحولها إلى جائحة هي إلى حد كبير في نطاق سيطرتنا وقد عرفنا ذلك نوعًا ما ولكن بعض الطرق التي
نحن نقوم بذلك بشكل مفاجئ حتى عندما
يتعلق الأمر بصحتنا الفردية ،
أعني ثمانين بالمائة من مناعتك
إذا قلت لا
تذهب أنت بحاجة إلى تحسين مناعتك ،
فماذا يعني ذلك حتى كيف
ستفعل ذلك ، فإن ثمانين بالمائة من مناعتك موجودة
بالفعل  أمعائك
، إنه
أيضًا مصدر كبير للسيروتونين الخاص بك من
خلال الطريقة التي يرتبط بها مزاجك
بشدة بأمعائك ، كيف يمكنك تحويل جسمك إلى
شخص يمكنه محاربة
هذا الفيروس بشكل أفضل أو على الأقل لا يمرض
منه أيضًا.  أنت في
الولايات المتحدة ، نعلم أن المواطنين
هنا هم أكثر عرضة
لعوامل الخطر التي تجعلهم
يعانون من مرض خطير سواء كانت السمنة سواء
كان ذلك بسبب مرض السكري سواء كان مرض الكلى المزمن ،
كل هذه الأنواع من
الأمراض هم من أمراض  الثراء الذي
يحدث في البلدان الغنية
تضررت البلدان الغنية بشدة من هذا
الوباء ، وعادة ما تفكر في عدوى جديدة
تفشيها وتعتقد أن
البلدان الفقيرة
ستتضرر أكثر من ذلك.  الحالة هنا كان
الأمر عكس ذلك تقريبًا ،
لماذا جزء منه هو ما تراه على
الشاشة هناك ، لذا فإن فكرة أننا يمكن أن نكون
مستعدين بشكل أفضل حتى للأشهر القليلة القادمة
ولكن أيضًا
للسنوات والعقود العديدة القادمة التي أعتقد أنها
في نطاق سلطتنا إلى حد كبير  وأردت الحصول على
وصفة طبية حقيقية حول كيفية الوصول إلى
هناك ، نعم والاستماع إلى الكثير من
العوامل مثل أننا بحاجة إلى رعاية
مشكلة السمنة لدينا في هذا البلد وهو
عامل مساهم ،
أنا متأكد من أنك ستوافق أو أريد  أن
أسألك هذا يا سانجاي لأنك
تتحدث عن أمعائك عندما
تتحدث عن أمعائك.
الحديث عن الميكروبيوم
نعم الميكروبيوم بحيث يكون
هذا النوع من الكون منكم يعرف
الكائنات الحية التي تعيش داخل أمعائنا
وهي مسؤولة جدًا عن مناعتنا
وعن العديد من الوظائف بصراحة
يسمونها الدماغ الثاني في ب
أنا وأنا فقط عرفنا دائمًا أن
هذا لم يتم تدريسه في كلية الطب ، لكنني
تعلمته بمفردي على مدار العقد الماضي
أو نحو ذلك ، ومن المثير للاهتمام
مرة أخرى أن أذهب إلى هذه الفكرة أن
ما سأذهب إليه  سأبالغ
قليلاً ولكن ما تناولته على
الإفطار هذا الصباح
يمكن أن يؤثر على مدى تأثرك
بالمرض الليلة
بسبب الميكروبيوم الخاص بك ، إنه
محدد إلى هذا الحد وهناك طرق
لوضع نفسك حقًا في أفضل
وضع ممكن  ليس فقط لمساعدتك على معرفة
التقليل من بعض تلك الأمراض التي رأيتها للتو
على الشاشة
ولكن لتقليل احتمالية
سئمتك من الطمع إذا أصبت به أو أحد
مسببات الأمراض المستقبلية ، فإن هذا
الجزء يضرب حقًا مرة أخرى هناك  هي
دول في جميع أنحاء العالم تظهر لك فقط
كوريا الجنوبية مقابل الولايات المتحدة ،
ولا أعرف ما إذا كان لدينا هذا ، فأنا أستخدم
هذا المثال دائمًا لأننا كنا مرضى
تم تشخيص أول مرضى
في نفس اليوم ،
لا تنظر إلى أن
اللون الأزرق هو كوريا الجنوبية  اللون الأحمر هو نحن ،
أعني أنهم سدس حجمنا
ولكن كيف تشرح أننا جميعًا
بشر ، ما الذي فعلوه بشكل
مختلف لدرجة أننا نعلم أن 43
مليون حالة مؤكدة في الاتحاد
شيء هناك
الدروس وستكون مهمة لأنه
مرة أخرى سيكون هناك المزيد من
مسببات الأمراض الناشئة هذه الفيروسات تستمر
في القفز إلى
البشر ولا يتعين عليهم التحول إلى أوبئة ،
يمكننا أن نكون الخط الأزرق في المرة القادمة
ولهذا السبب أردت حقًا
كتابة  كتاب